Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
Soy Luis Muñoz conversamos con Guillermo
Arriaga reconocido escritor y guionista
mexicano o como él mismo se define
chilango Muchas gracias Guillermo por
estar en la entrevista de Frank 24 no
muchas gracias a ti y a todos que están
aquí usted acaba de publicar extrañas en
la editorial Penguin Random House una
historia del siglo XVIII basada en
Inglaterra sobre un Rebelde aristócrata
que decide dar su vida por los más
abandonados de la sociedad qué nos dice
esta historia de usted y que nos dice
también de la sociedad de hoy
Espero que yo tenga el mismo el mismo
sentido de empatía de compasión y de
empuje hacia la consecución de metas que
tiene el personaje William Burton
William Burton es un muchacho de 15 años
un aristócrata es primogénito de una de
una de una casa aristócrata dueño de
miles de Acres pero miles estamos
hablando de cien mil Acres y una fortuna
incalculable y su padre lo manda a
recorrer las las aldeas para que lo
vayan conociendo los pobladores y vaya
viendo Cuáles son los problemas él le
parece fastidioso hacerlo pero un día
cuando se baja a ver unos Corrales donde
hay vacas ve una figura desnuda
blanquecina en en en en Corral amarraron
encadenaba un poste y brinca las trancas
y el administrador dice dónde vas Quiero
ver qué es eso que es un becerro que es
eso que está ahí no es nada Vámonos dijo
no voy a ver y es un ser humano es un
ser humano que está encadenado y y y con
candados
que en realidad son un muchacho con
parálisis cerebral
y William Burton lo ve y dice pero es
una persona me dijo No no es una persona
es un animal nacido hombre y mujer dice
no es una persona
es un animal no habla no se mueve sé
cuánto tiempo tiene aquí desde que nació
si desde que nació vive aquí sí ahí vive
encadenado y esto le le perturba dice
cómo puede haber este secreto estas son
una puse en la garganta de de la
propiedad y si hay más como esto mijo ya
no preguntes ya acá ya habla con tu
padre mi padre sabe de esto
Cuántos más hay yo voy a hacer que va a
regir aquí Quiero saber cuántos más ahí
dicen no pues hay otros cuatro o cinco
Llévame con el otro y esto es una mujer
con aspectos asiáticos desnuda
atada entre las gallinas en un gallinero
y esto perturba la vida de de William
Burton el protagonista
al grado que prefiere renunciar a su
herencia y dedicarse a la medicina por
hacer algo por estos seres que
administrar una fortuna incalculable la
novedad está centrada en un momento en
el desarrollo de la ciencia en esa lucha
de la ciencia contra la religión la
aristocracia ese oscurantismo hoy
también llevándolo un poco al presente
estamos todos como un poco fascinados
con la Inteligencia artificial es ahora
la ciencia en este momento su propio
límite ella misma yo creo que la virtud
de la ciencia es que nos hizo voltear
hacia el ser humano y tratar de que la
vida del ser humano fuera lo más
[Música]
llevadera posible la cura de las
enfermedades
las mejoras de de
la vida hasta la construcción de los
móviles y las cámaras etcétera etcétera
Pero
la ciencia debe pienso la ciencia debe
tener un límite cuando se pierde la
perspectiva del humano creo que el
Humano debe ser siempre la perspectiva
que guíe la ciencia y en América Latina
todavía hay muchas creencias ancestrales
en México en Colombia Cómo se relaciona
usted con esos mundos yo creo que todo
país tiene creencias ancestrales
y creo que todo país de alguna manera se
relaciona con esas creencias ancestrales
aquí por ejemplo España y Francia tienen
un pasado fuertísimo con el que no no no
hay no hay manera de evadir hasta en la
misma arquitectura igual sucede con
México y Colombia las creencias
ancestrales
permitiendo alguna manera las culturas
contemporáneas pero suceden todos los
países no no no no no no no creo que
estén exentos unos países de las que
ancestrales que a otros al contrario
creo que todos están vinculados a ello
volviendo a William barton al
protagonista usted hablaba antes de esa
empatía que le caracteriza durante toda
la novela una de sus mensajes es también
esa
en la mirada del otro también nos
encontramos
yo yo creo que
que es importante la alteridad y la
alteridad consiste en
quién soy A partir del otro García
Márquez decía estoy enamorado del hombre
que soy contigo
cuando le decía a la mujer que amaba no
O sea amo el que soy contigo y entonces
el otro el que a veces te permite
descubrir quién eres Yo soy parte del
arte la función del arte la función de
la literatura es que a través de algo
escrito por otro Este
puedo yo saber quién soy y aquí puedo
encontrar parte de mí mismo que no hay
en en en que no puedo descubrir de otra
manera y esta otra
alteridad que es el libro el cuadro La
música es la construcción de otro para
Encontrarme a mí mismo
también para encontrarse con esas
extrañas de William Burton usted también
ha dicho en otras ocasiones que apoya
las causas de la discapacidad que dice
también nuestra sociedad de hoy ha
habido un avance en el trato a esas
personas Pues sí claro que hay un avance
aún siguen siendo de los
sectores de la sociedad más olvidados
me platicaron en Santander
que hasta hace algunos años encontraron
a personas con discapacidad amarrada con
los animales tal como lo escribe el
libro y este hombre me decía No puedo
creer que en Europa del Siglo 21 que en
mi propio país se cometan estos
atrocidades creo que hay que avanzar con
respecto a los prejuicios Hay que ser
muy empáticos ya que darles espacios
donde ellos se puedan desarrollar y
oportunidades de acuerdo a sus a sus
limitaciones y a sus ventajas Es
importante saber por ejemplo que en la
discapacidad
alguna discapacidad hacen se compensan
de otra manera
las personas con síndrome de down tienen
un extraordinario talento musical y y
visual son grandes artistas visuales
hay gentes con parálisis que pueden
elaborar grandes teorías y que
precisamente por no tener movimiento
están concentrados en su mente Stephen
hawkings es una muestra de ello o sea el
tener una discapacidad no implica que no
tengas capacidad simplemente son otro
tipo de capacidades por eso se habla
ahora también de personas con con
capacidades diferentes más que personal
con discapacidad otro de los temas de la
novela es la libertad la valentía que
también tiene William barton yo quería
preguntarle a usted todo el mundo tiene
un contexto privilegiado como para
permitirse esa libertad o esa valentía
no también depende de los privilegios a
ver a veces no no creo que todo mundo
tenga los privilegios
en mi país donde 54% de la población
vive bajo debajo de la línea de pobreza
no puedes decir
cuál libertad No o sea es un lujo
también claro Ser valiente y libre Claro
que es un lujo puede ser valiente libre
porque tiene la oportunidad de ser
Valiente y libre pero cuando lo único
que te queda es subsistir de la manera
que que mejor puedas Yo he estado con
amigos míos gente cercana con la que
mantengo contacto una vez a la semana
campesinos analfabetas del norte de
Tamaulipas somos compadres son padres
nuestros hijos yo los vi comer tacos de
aceite donde alguna vez cocinaron carne
porque ya no les alcanza para más
y las enfermedades que sufren la
diabetes sobre todo es porque lo único
que les alcanza para comprar una botella
de coca-cola llena de azúcar que les da
la energía porque no tiene otra cosa que
comer entonces
ahí si dices que valentía hay que
libertad
y sin embargo estas personas te lo voy a
decir de mi compadre Lucio Estrada
tiene un sentido de la alegría de vivir
que me sorprende aún en la adversidad
más brutal estos estos tienen una
profunda alegría y una profunda
hospitalidad conmigo han sido
hospitalarios y me han dado lo poco que
tienen me han dado han repartido no
viene el señor dale un octavo de lo que
de lo que vamos a comer no Entonces
sí la Valentina liberal tiene que ver
con la posición donde estás en
privilegio ahora tampoco vemos por
sentado los privilegios
algunos privilegios en conquistaron con
fuerza no y otros privilegios se
perdieron por desidia
valentía y Libertad sí que ha habido en
la forma de la novela usted no ha
escrito ni qué Ni aunque ni por qué
palabras de antes del siglo XVIII
también pocas puntuaciones este juego
también le ha servido a usted después de
una prolífica carrera como para jugar
más que jugar es
el tratar de someter todas las
herramientas a contar la historia y el
lenguaje es una de las herramientas
Cómplices para narrar una historia y lo
que yo quería es que se sintiera que
estaba leyendo un libro del siglo XVIII
y por eso quería que las palabras que
utilizaras fueran acuñadas antes de 1781
Entonces sí sí sí hay un
una
elaboración de lenguaje al servicio de
la historia más que como juego como
herramienta para contar la historia A lo
mejor posible vamos ya terminando con
dos preguntas Hay una que me llama la
atención de su biografía y es que usted
perdió el olfato en su adolescencia Qué
olor le queda en la mente o echa de
menos me queda el olor de
de la flor del naranjo
Ese fue quizás de los últimos olores que
tuve pero cosa curiosa no sé por qué
razón puedo leer a ciertos animales a
distancia
a los cerdos salvajes los puedo leer a
cien metros a los pecaríes los puedo
leer a cien metros no sé por qué esos
animales en particular los puedo leer
los vuelos de lejos Digo por aquí hay
por aquí está cerca un pecadillo por
aquí está cerca un un Marrano salvaje un
cerdo salvaje hablando de los recuerdos
usted siempre reivindicado su origen de
barrio estamos en un momento en el que
ciudades como la mía Barcelona la suya
Ciudad de México Bogotá también Medellín
está cada vez más llena de nómadas
digitales cómo sería en esta nueva
realidad gentrificada Amores perros por
ejemplo mira
los barrios a los que están llegando son
barrios que ya estaban gentrificados
entonces
tan tremendamente ejemplificados
No creo que ningún americano se vaya a
vivir a donde yo crecí tramo Amores
perros hay parten Condesa por ejemplo sí
está gentrificada desde que filmamos
amores pero lleva muchos años
gentrificada es nuestros ojos Por cierto
yo conocí el Soho en
1979 cuando era peligroso con ganas era
un lugar donde estaba lleno de bodegas
para los muelles por eso son los Porque
eran las bodegas y un amigo mío que
estaba era el fotógrafo este Michael se
fue a hacer la película de fame
y vivía ahí y ahora ve que es ojo No
todavía hay lugares donde puedes ir a
encontrar esa esencia de barrio que le
gusta no este pero siempre he dicho yo
salí del barrio pero el barrio no salió
de mí
no con esa frase terminamos Muchas
gracias por esta conversación en France
24 al contrario Pueden seguir más
contenidos como este en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]